There is one final step
that you need to consider
before this place picker integration
is complete, and that is attributions.
When displaying data from the Google
places API for Android, such as
auto complete results or place name and
address, there is some attribution and
Google local requirements
that you must comply with.
The requirements apply to
the Place Picker UI widget as well
any programmatic API calls.
So if your app has retrieved
a place via the Place Picker and
then shows this data on a follow
up screen without a map,
the app must also show attributions
on this follow up screen.
So we have the Powered by Google image
included in the Google repository
in the correct sizes that you need for
Android apps.
You can reference it directly by name
as Powered by Google and then light or
dark, depending on if you're
using a light background or
a dark one respectively.
But note that this Powered by Google
resource is just an image, and
therefore, this text
will not be localized.
So, you can see our integration for
attributions in the GitHub
commit linked below, or you can feel
free to play with the layouts and
where you would want to
place an attribution image.
There are also special
considerations for
attributions for
third party content, so be sure to
check the documentation linked in the
instructor notes for more information.
And if you would like to see what
else the Play Safe has to offer,
there's a link in the instructor
notes for you as well.